chris hogan here i've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that i run into might surprise
you you're gonna get a glimpse into the
life of a self-made millionaire who
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss it people this is
millionaire
Becky and I both come from what we
called a modest standard of living in
both of our families and so we
appreciate the value of money well we
didn't win the lottery we didn't you
know it is big in the stock market we
haven't inherited any money this is
serious business money you know we've
been entrusted with this and we don't
take it lightly we we took a pretty
serious approach and we decided that
we're gonna stick to this plan
we know that we're in it together we're
not pitted against one another I think
if we weren't on the same page I don't
know how you could stay on the same plan
[Music]
kind of our first like goal if you will
Becky wanted to be a stay home mom so we
decided at that point we need to start
living off of my income so that if she
decides she want to stay home that we
could do it from that point after we had
kids it began hey our next goal is we
want to be able to pay for our son's
college not have to go into any debt and
not have them incur any debt so once we
achieved that milestone then it was like
okay the only debt we have is our
mortgage in our home so we became
diligent at that point about hey our
next goal is we want to pay off our
mortgage and once we kind of got there
the next milestone began I want to get
to a point for us financially where I
can work because I want to not because I
have to and we want to be in a position
where if we wanted to we could but if I
want to keep working I wanted to be able
to enjoy it and I actually enjoyed it
more when I knew I didn't have to once I
made the decision to retire then it kind
of became about I think a couple of
things one having some fun together and
the second one was being able to give
really more than we had in the past in
retiring at an early age and being
healthy both of us gave us opportunity
to go and do more and travel and do fun
things and also just start more giving
to various ministries that we believe in
it can be individuals that are raising
money to go on a mission trip just any
kind of specialty gift that we wanted to
would want to gift to somebody and she
sees a need she can just write a check
and give as she pleases
[Music]
early on our marriage we figured out
three principles and I'm not sure
exactly where we got it but we came up
with three principles that we wanted to
live by number one everything belongs to
God because we believe everything we
have has been entrusted to us by God we
live by that principle of being thankful
and feeling this we have a
responsibility to be good stewards we
ask God to guide us and help us make the
right decision because left up to Arang
we're gonna probably mess it up
somewhere our second principle was we've
got to understand the difference between
needs and wants we had to make some hard
decisions about yeah I know we really
want that but we don't really need that
right now and so we did that early in
our marriage and then we started putting
some money away start hitting some of
these milestones that I share with you
and then our third principle was
everyone can use a budget we took a
notepad and we really wrote down the
left side of the ledger we wrote down
okay what are our income levels that
we're bringing home on the right side
what are our expenses on a monthly basis
the first year we do that we thought hey
we got a little money left over so we
actually earmark that to savings we
didn't just like get through the month
and it's like if there's anything left
we'll save it
we actually used it as an item that we
assigned a place to keep being use the
budget you just if you have it it great
but you gotta use the budget yeah yeah
you can't just talk about it yeah so if
you live by those three principles
anybody can achieve what we have because
it hasn't been magical we've kind of
been a boring just stick to the plan and
over time it's gonna pay off
early on in your life early on in your
marriage
early on your career don't be enticed by
what the world says you need to have
make difficult decisions based on if you
can afford to pay cash for it if we
couldn't pay cash for it we didn't and
to me that just makes sense and there's
a lot of different ways that you can
save money we love to go out to eat
particularly now that there are no
children around yeah no children have to
pay for but we we always enjoyed early
on using coupons or using a discount
card we have fun with it and I'll say
hey we can go here tonight and we got
they got a buy one get one free or we
can go here and we can save $10 if you
spend 30 to me it's still like a
competitive fun thing for us to like hey
we still get to go out but we're saving
money while we did I'm not saying that
that there hadn't been tense moments
they're happy and even though he was the
primary breadwinner and I contributed a
little bit along the way we knew the
plan was because we were both committed
to it
when we first got married your first job
as a schoolteacher what was yourself I
wasn't making $11,000 she was making
eleven thousand a year I was in a job
making fifteen thousand a year even
though we weren't making a lot of money
we decided at that point we're gonna
live on less than we make
we actually instill the discipline of
hey when I get a raise I don't want to
go spin more this is an opportunity for
us to put more away because we're living
off this now let's just don't raise our
standard of living because we're making
more money and anybody can do that but I
think the key is making sure my expenses
are less than what I'm bringing home and
those principles work for any income
level and we know that because we did it
if you have a hard discussion early on
in your marriage and you come together
on the same thinking you can stick to it
and we did that when we knew that you
all were gonna talk to us about it I
went back and I thought I know we came
up with that somewhere but I don't
remember when and where and I found a
piece of paper that I had written down I
think we taught it maybe in our church
in a young adult married class or
something and we use that as our
guideline back in when we've just been
married just for a very short amount of
time to help us get started and so
that's stuck with us our entire marriage
those three principles we know those are
there they're fact-based and they're
specific enough that you can embrace
them yeah
we want to encourage you to get you a
piece of paper out get you a pen and
write those three principles down and
then figure out how can I do that and
start putting together your own plan
your budget would look different than
then our budget did and your needs
versus once aren't going to be the same
needs and once the asserted that we've
gone through we put a plan together we
executed the plan I'm fortunate to sit
here today and say we did pay and now we
can play and but we play in a way where
it's not just for us it's also for
others responsibly playing with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]